So, yeah, you want to go ahead and ask
me the same exact question?
I just prove that he's a Muslim, that's
all.
So, for Jesus, so when you look at
Jesus, he has a beginning, he was born
through Mary, he has a middle, he lived
his life, you know, uh brought people
back from the dead, had his prophecy,
lived on Earth, uh was born through Mary
and everything. So, he had a present
while he was on Earth. He also has, you
know, to fulfill his uh his present life
as well as he's going to be uh to us,
he's not going to be resurrected. To us,
he's going to be brought back to life or
or or brought brought back to this Earth
to defeat the Antichrist, right? So, to
defeat the Antichrist, uh you know, the
the similarity, there's a lot of
similarities between Christianity and
Islam. Respectfully, respectfully, my
friend. I I know what you believe as a
Muslim. I know I know what you believe
as a Muslim. I just want you to bring
evidence that he was indeed a Muslim
historically. So, I know that the Quran
says that Jesus was a Muslim, not in
those words, but you know, it it implies
it. Cuz his disciples were Muslim, he
believed in Allah of the Quran. That's
what it says. Right. Right. Right. I'm
just now
I'm I'm asking for verification of that
claim that Jesus was a Muslim
historically.
So, historically, Jesus was a Muslim cuz
he submitted to God. So, anyone who
submits to God is a Muslim. That Muslim
is not necessarily So, I want you to
sort of like pause for a second and
don't look at Islam or or being a Muslim
as a religion, but as even if there was
no Quran Islam or person that follows
Islam is Muslim, right? So, think of
somebody just submitting to God, right?
So, so in order for you to submit to a
higher being, you have to be created by
them. So, for him to be a Muslim, right?
In order for him to be a somebody who's
submissive or submitting to the the
words of God, the path of God, the the
the the message of God that that you
know, when he came down, when Jesus was
here, right? Every single prophet that
was, you know, brought onto Earth,
Prophet Adam, Prophet Moses, Jesus, you
know, who is Isa
So you you believe you believe everybody
submitted to God, okay. Every Yes, sir.
I got you.
Yep. So if I if I say I submit to God,
all right, I submit to God, okay. The
God that I believe in is is a statue
that I have in my house.
Am I a Muslim? I believe that that
statue is my creator.
You're not a Muslim.
the higher being. It is it is it is a
grave sin for us to even close our eyes
and imagine what God is. That's how
grand he is. So it is I cannot Wait,
where do you where do you get that from?
Wait, wait, wait, stop, stop, stop. Slow
down, slow down.
go ahead, go ahead. Where do you get it
Where do you get Where do you get it
from that it's a grave sin to try to to
even imagine God? Where do you Where
does that come from? Yeah. So do you do
you know we literally when what happened
in Denmark? You can't even do a draw a
picture of Prophet Muhammad without you
getting like, you know, unalived by a
Muslim after he gets pissed off. So
imagine Oh, so you're you're saying So
you're saying So you're saying it's
wrong.
God is God is times a million how we
thought think about God. So just Wait,
just just just to be clear, so you're
saying
So you brought in the religion of Islam
again cuz you at first you said, "Let's
take out the, you know, Islam as a
religion. Let's take out the religion
and just focus on the definition of the
word Muslim." Yeah. Um and like I kind
of did that. As soon as As soon as I did
that, you brought Islam into it. You see
how it's inseparable?
So so your your literal question is
prove Jesus was Muslim. Somebody who was
Muslim
Yeah, so wait, wait, first first first
Wait, first I was dealing with first I
was dealing with your definition.
You said that all you have to do
to be a Muslim
is submit your will to God, a higher
being. That's what you said. So, your
creator. Let me let me let me If I
submit my will to God, and I believe
that this God is a statue, am I a
Muslim? You said, "No."
And so, I'm asking, "Why am I not a
Muslim?" Yeah, why why not? If I submit
to a statue who I believe is God, my
creator. Because we have what's called
the word of God. It literally has
pointed out the graveness, right? So, as
in in the
even even in the Bible, even in the
Bible, right? It talks about a higher
being.
My brother That's fine. So, so does the
So, you're not listening to what I'm
saying. You're choosing not to listen to
what I'm saying. No, but no. I I No,
trust No, trust me, dude. Please. I
Don't think that I'm like not listening
to you. I want you to know that I
understand exactly what you're saying,
bro. You just got to hear what I'm
trying to say, right? Well, I I just I
just want you to know that I know
exactly what you're saying.
Because now you're saying, you know,
even even the Bible talks about, you
know, worshipping God, the higher being,
the creator. A higher being. Yes. So, so
does So, does the Book of Mormon.
So do the So do the the scripts of
Egypt. Which talks about Amun Ra and
their gods. Yes.
the Book of the
Dead. You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, yeah, it's okay. Can I finish the
sentence real quick? Can you give me 15
seconds? Yes, so
Okay. So, yeah, how how does me
specifically This is Wait, wait, stop,
dude.
I want you to answer specifically
why me worshipping, me believing, and
submitting to a statue as my God is not
being Muslim. Just that directly,
please. So, the the answer to that is
the statue is something that's a part of
creation. It's something that God has
created. How do you How do you know
that? Because I know that. That's That's
That's a human-made object. It didn't
just appear out of thin air. You just
literally said it's a statue that
somebody made that put that's in my
house.
So, you cannot God
Well, how do you know that God is not a
statue? part of creation. Yeah, how do
you know that God is not a statue?
Because you cannot even fathom God.
There's no There's no beginning, middle,
and there's no space. There's no
What What Where are you getting it from?
Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude. Dude.
I'm asking you for your source of where
you're getting this from. What is your
substantiation that you can't even
imagine God or that God is not a statue?
Where are you getting this from?
It's It's in every religion, man. It's
in logic. No, it's not.
No, it's not in every religion because
again
It's in science. If you go If you go to
the Hindu religion, they they worship
statues. If you go to God is not a
scientific not a scientific matter. He's
metaphysical. He's beyond science. So,
it's not a scientific matter.
There is hundreds of scientific proofs
in the Bible and the Quran. Like the
Like the rotation of the of the Earth
going around the moon around the sun.
It's It's written in the Quran. There's
literally like in in your hand your
phone or whatever, right? So, there
they're literally in Mohammed. Mohammed,
you don't you don't have to do this.
Mohammed, you don't have to do this.
All you have to do is tell me where
you're getting it from. If you want to
say the Quran, thank you for answering
the question. If you want to say the
Bible, thank you for answering the
question. If you want to say the
Bhagavad Gita or Book of Mormon or
something else, thank you for answering
the question.
Right. Right. Right. So, my question is
where are you getting it from that God
is unimaginable and he's not a statue?
Where is Where are you getting that
from? From the From the Quran. From the
Quran. Thank you. Thank you so much.
Yes. So, you're getting it from the
Quran. Yes. So, you're using the Quran
Yes. to to establish who and what God
is, right? Right. Right. Okay. And so,
if somebody is
is saying that they are
You go ahead. If somebody is submitting
to something that they call God that
does not match the qualifiers you find
in the Quran, then they are not a Muslim
and not submitting to the true God,
right? Correct. Correct. Okay. Do you
know what the baseline is? There's only
one baseline. There is
There is no God but Let me just Let me
just land it with this and I'll pass it
to you. Right. Let me land it with this
and I'll pass it to you. So, being a
Muslim is not as simple as just submit
to God and you're a Muslim. No, it's
specifically submit to the God in the
Quran and then you're a Muslim, right?
Right. So, can I go ahead and speak or
do you go Are you continuing?
Yes. Go ahead.
All right. You're good. So, when the
first When the first man, right? Even Do
you know Adam and Eve, right? The first
man and woman,
right? So, they were not They were not
people of Earth.
It's in the Quran. It's in the Bible.
It's in the Torah. They were actually um
human beings in paradise, right? Sorry,
in the Bible In the Bible it says that
they were on Earth. Paradise was on
Earth. I know in the Quran paradise When
they ate When they ate the When When
When Adam and Eve ate the apple, that's
when they got banished to Earth. Just
FYI, you need to read up on the
Quran. That's in the That's in the
Quran, not the Bible. That's That's in
the Quran, not the Bible. Go ahead. From
the Quran, go When they When they When
they made a mistake and and bit into it,
uh well, that's another topic, right?
So, what So, what happened is what I'm
trying to say is, right? Human beings
Human beings are susceptible to making
mistakes. That's what that is, right?
So, that's why So, even even prophets
are susceptible to making mistakes. So,
what I'm saying is So, when every single
prophet came out with that with a
message, I'm trying to get to that, bro.
If I let you speak, you got to let me
speak, okay? So, that's what I'm trying
to tell you. I let people speak as long
as they're on point. You're not even on
the Dude, I'm trying to tell I'm trying
to speak and you're I can't get 5
seconds out. That's what I'm trying to
tell you, man. So, every single prophet
that has
You got more than 5 seconds out and you
started with that that has come out with
a message. That was a message to say,
"Hey, look, you're not living your life
properly." So, when if if prophet Noah,
the Noah's Ark, the same exact story,
when they were like all the What does
this have to do with proving that Jesus
is a Muslim?
My dude, when Jesus came out, he came
out with the same exact message as every
other prophet. Okay. That that world
that that the human beings that are
living on this world are not living
righteously.
That's what it is. Okay, so let's get
let's let's get straight to this now.
And the last message that came out was
from prophet Muhammad. Way after Thank
you. Thank you, Muhammad.
So, Muhammad, Muhammad, Muhammad, I need
you to I need you to refocus. So, we
have established that to be a Muslim
is to submit to the God of the Quran.
The God that is described in the Quran.
That's who you have to submit to to be a
Muslim.
So, what I need you to do is I need you
to show me that Jesus submitted to the
God the same God that's described in the
Quran. That's what I need you to do.
Okay. Okay. So, do you know do you know
so I I forget exactly what verse is in
the original in in in in in in in the
Old Testament in the in the Bible?
Right? Do you know about Do you know
about the way that that Jesus worshiped?
Jesus Do you know about how you know
Jesus it's Jesus Jesus spoke in the New
Testament, bro, not the not the Old
Testament. Yeah. In his earthly
ministry, he's in the New Testament. Do
you know how Jesus prayed? Do you know
how Do you know how he prayed? Explain
to me how Jesus prayed and who he prayed
to. Who did he pray to? Cuz he can't
pray to himself, right?
okay. Well, let me Can I answer you?
Yes, please, please. You're talking
about how Jesus prayed?
Jesus prayed by calling God his father
and I didn't identifying himself as as
God's son. That's how he prayed. So, he
prayed to his father. Okay. Is Allah his
father?
What Allah is not his father. Allah is
his creator. Then he's not a Muslim.
Who's not a Muslim? Jesus is not a
Muslim since he's not praying to Allah.
He's praying to his father.
Who's not Allah?
Jesus, why would he Do you pray to your
father? Does it Does that even make
logical sense? Why would you pray to
your father? Yeah. Yeah, I pray to my
father. I pray to my father.
to your father. You pray to your father.
Oh, you Oh, whatever I think your
Whatever your name is God logic, right?
You have a father that you were born
through, right? Your father. Your
biological father. Yeah. Yeah, I have a
father. I have a I have a biological
father and I have a heavenly father. And
Jesus Jesus said that God is his father
and he prayed to to his father.
have a heavenly father, brother.
You have a creator which is God.
I got you. That's That's fine. That's
fine. You can say that. So, to believe
that I have a heavenly father means that
I'm not a Muslim, right? Cuz I'm not
talking about Allah. That's That's not
Allah, right? Yeah. Yeah, no. You You
You're not a Muslim. You're You're I
guess Christian and whatever.
Very good.
Whatever or a different denomination
that Christians That's exactly 4,000
different Bibles that y'all believe in.
what Jesus Bro. Bro. Bro. That's exactly
what Jesus said. Jesus prayed to who he
said is his heavenly father. And by by
default he's not a Muslim then. Just
like I'm not a Muslim because I'm
praying to what I what I consider my
heavenly father.
And I can't be a Muslim by doing that.
Jesus is not a Muslim cuz that's what he
did. Right. So, so the distinction is a
couple of things, right? So, you prayed
to the God the Father, right? That's the
relationship within the Trinity and the
relationship in Christianity, right? So,
in in Christianity we'll we'll say this,
right? So, this is what you're saying.
Jesus prayed to God the Father who
basically is part of the Holy Trinity,
correct? Yes or no? Yeah, he prayed to
the father who is another who is a
person of the Trinity. Right. Right. So,
so so that's that's what I'm saying,
right? So, and then in Islam, right?
What we're trying to say is there's no
notion of a heavenly father as part of
anything that's related to that, right?
So, what I'm trying to say is So, so, so
there is which which 4,000 versions of
the Bible do you are you referring to? I
want to know that.
All of them. All of them.
All of them.
No, because no, no, because one says
that he's worshipping God, the other one
says the father. No, they all say he's
worshipping the father. No, they do not.
No, they do not.
Okay. All right, so this is what I want
you to do, Muhammad. Okay? This is what
I want you to do. Cuz number one, you're
the one who brought up the Bible, not
me. You said even in the Bible, it shows
that Jesus submitted to God. Cuz look,
how did he pray in the Bible? And so now
I just told you how he prayed. He prayed
to God, his father. And so by
definition, he's not a Muslim. But now
you're saying, "Oh, well, that's
changed." So, you appealed to the Bible,
not me. Right. But now what I This is
what I need you to do.
When Jesus prayed to his father, right?
When he bowed down and prostrated. I'll
give you the I'll give you the verse
here. It's Mark chapter 14, verse 36.
It's in both of them.
Right. It's in Mark chapter 14, verse
36. But And it's also in Matthew 26,
verse 39. Okay?
Right. So, now
Go to Let me finish. Let me finish. All
right. All right, go ahead. Go ahead. Go
ahead.
So, what I want you to do is is I want
you to find me a version of the Bible
where it doesn't say father
I already
Whenever you're ready.
Whenever you're ready, I've got it.
ahead. All right. Go ahead. All right.
John 20:17. I am ascending to my father
and your father.
Wait a second. Wait a second. So, I'm
going to I'm going to give you what your
reference is, and then I'm going to give
you Matthew and Mark to where he talks
about my God. Can I go ahead and do
that? No. No. You're wasting your time,
and you're wasting my time. You told me
that the You said that in the versions,
it was changed. One version says father,
when another version omits father and
just says God. I want you to show me
any version where it doesn't say father
in those particular verses. So,
specifically Matthew Matthew 27:46
and Mark 15:42.
I said Matthew 26.
No, I'm saying Matthew 26. I'm saying
Matthew 27. The Matthew 26 is not the
entire Bible, is it? You got You also
got verse 27, right?
I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
give you one last chance. I'm going to
give you one last chance to comprehend
what's going on here. Here's your last
chance. So, you asked me how did Jesus
pray? And I gave you a reference of how
Jesus prayed.
And the reference that I gave you was
Mark 14:36
and Matthew 26:39,
where Jesus, when he prostrates, he
calls God father when he prays. You
rebutted by saying, "Well, what What
version of the Bible are you talking
about because there's some versions of
the Bible where it will say father
there, and there's another version of
the Bible where it doesn't say father.
It will just say God." So, this is what
you needed me to do. This is what I need
you to do. Right. Give me a version of
the Bible
where Mark 14:36
or Matthew 26:39
does not have the word father. Do you
understand the assignment? Yeah, can I
read off Matthew 26:39 for the for the
listeners? Can I read that off?
Yep.
Yep. Okay. All right. And Matthew 26:39,
"And going a little further, he fell on
his face and prayed, saying, 'My father,
if it is possible, let this cup pass
from me. Nevertheless, not as I will,
but as you will, right?' That's what
you're saying, right?"
That's what it Jesus said. So, show me a
version of the Bible of that verse where
it doesn't say father.
you when you continue to read, right?
So, in the in in the Torah, the
Bible, the Quran, God is always
referenced to as a male, as a he and and
and even in the version
What does this have to do with you
getting a different version?
do with it, man. You're not
The verse doesn't say father in that
verse.
It's got everything to do with it. What
I'm trying to say is
So, stop wasting my time and get me the
version that's different.
Yes, Matthew 27:46 and Mark 15:34. My
God
You can't make this up.
Sometimes I wish I could.
No, he got it.
He just ran.
He got it.
He just ran away.
You can't make this up.